[Music]
miss tilly
i'm afraid i only have a few minutes
let's get right to it
yesterday your network yarovision was
hijacked by
don't rebels shoot
they called for the liberation of
so-called outcasts from the vero labor
camps is vivero produced with slave
labor
saves millions of lives do you think
that those lives care where it comes
from you were imprisoned at the age of
13 the same age as diego you spend a lot
of time with your father
she is a great teacher a lion finds calm
before the kill
fire me
i understand you were forced to endure
15 years of hard labor pruning tobacco i
hear you still have the blade
when yara becomes paradise
my methods
no one will care
you are the only survivor i watch
castillo order a whole boat of our
people shot to death
get as far away as you can from that
psychopath all of you
a revolution is not won by the fearless
it's won by the fear
welcome to libertad danny
i have a vision to rebuild paradise
a cure viviro the most effective
treatment for cancer the world has ever
seen grown
within our precious tobacco but our
paradise comes at a cost this our
enemies will never understand out
now your safety's on
you want me to kill anton castillo
kill a dictator who has raped our land
and turned our people into slaves
thinking about it
what about you you're gonna be a
hungarian legend
i'm not fearless
but i promise you one thing
i will be here
there are lions there are lamps
you are alive
and we eat the
lambs
play it on the all-new xbox
you